when did you first start kind of
assessing china
started assessing china in the
mid-1990s took place in 1979 with them
xiao pink
so you let's say you've had 15 16 years
of opening take place by the mid 90s
but then when you go
to
investors to look for money they were
still quite skeptical that china can
amount to anything at all
property rights were not well
established so you had to depend on
economic variables and the management
skill
to see whether you would get paid or
your foreign direct investment would pay
off
i remember going to one large investor
and we spent two hours making a
presentation a group of us
top down bottom up what we are trying to
say
and so when we in the middle of it after
about an hour
when two of us left for a rest break we
go out and we say
we are going to get a lot of money with
this investor
and two hours pass by and one of one
person then says uh how much do you
think you're going to invest
and the answer is
invest oh i'm not going to invest
anything
i'm here to see who would be so crazy as
to go and make an investment in china
yeah that was the approach in the mid
90s
so we have come a long way
and after 1995
after 2000 especially after the world
trade
organization in 1901 that you mentioned
china became the darling of foreign
investors
but now i think once again
you're at a critical juncture
and country risk becomes very important
let me may i explore why please please
this is a very very hot topic right now
here are the reasons
you do not have country risk the way i
started to study in 1980 they are not
running short of foreign exchange
normally when you look at argentina or
brazil and there is a problem the
exchange rate goes kaput they just
depreciate like crazy not happening and
you read about these countries that are
running low on their foreign reserves
right these thin cushions and how
dangerous it could be yes that is not
happening or you find that in the case
of mexico in 1981 the foreign exchange
reserves were close to zero i went to
the
deputy head of the central bank and said
in spanish very
nicely how much reserves do you have
this is something the imf used to put
out of course and the answer i get is
information
so you don't have the problem with china
today the foreign exchange reserves are
huge and they are a creditor to the
whole world then where does the risk
come from
you have to modify your thinking the
risk comes from the fact the communist
party is supreme
and you cannot cross roads with them
and you've had companies which have had
a difficulty in the stock market
because they did do something to show
that their company was more important
than the country or the communist party
we learned that's a no-no
so why does the country risk increase
because there are some companies that
you think are very good but it is not
going to work out if they run a foul of
the senior man senior management of the
country that is one issue
we think of jack ma and alibaba
both happened not only that but i was
astounded
the tutoring companies
they came down and the reason for that
daniel
was the fact that if you are dealing
with tutoring and if you run a tutoring
company
only i can afford to send my child to
your tutoring school the others cannot
so my child gets into a better
university other children do not and the
class distinction gets wider
and the communist party is threatened
[Music]